even cami uh catfish this is going into
what season what now
it's still season eight it's a
continuation of season eight
okay so with nate and you turn it on its
side
essentially it's just infinity what it
feels like
right when all of this happened when you
realized that you couldn't leave the
house and people weren't meeting
did you immediately know that the show
would still work
as well as it does uh
i mean look we've we've been making for
a long time and
throughout the years we've always looked
for ways to improve
or perhaps change things up
we've obviously found a format that
works really well but doesn't mean that
we're not always thinking
you know what if or could we do this or
how could we maybe make this work and so
we've always sort of thought
is there a way that you know if people
are
either too far away or unavailable to
meet in person that we could do
something with video chat
because it's obviously already a part of
the show um
and so we were excited i think actually
to try it to have an excuse to really
kind of take apart the existing format
and bring in some new elements uh
not convinced it would work immediately
but i think
after we filmed the first episode we
knew
that had gone really well it felt
awesome and and
it worked and uh tammy your permanent
role
on the show now um i love the dynamic
of you in these situations did you know
that you were good at this
i mean yes and no i don't i don't know i
so i think you know even i were actually
talking about this yesterday but i feel
like
you know being the oldest sister of six
girls
i kind of know how to like mediate but
also you know
check people in when they're wrong and
you know i think that that comes
naturally to me and
giving advice comes naturally to me but
catfish is like a whole different animal
so there's no
telling how you'll be until you're
actually
in the situation um because anything can
happen
well that's the thing is that you know
in the you know in 2020
ins we don't we don't head into
confrontation and we have no desire to
manage confrontation
if somebody says something we don't like
we just block them so this is almost
like it's almost like you guys are the
last of a dying breed who
you know can sort of navigate you know
this this kind of world
yeah i mean it's it's chaotic and it's
crazy
but at the end of the day you know our
job is to help people
and you know whether that means
connecting them or
telling them that maybe they need to go
their separate ways or
you know giving people like the honest
truth about something in a situation
whatever it is like we're there to help
regardless of what it looked like
was it how difficult was it to get
people to reveal
um but over over zoom was it was it more
difficult was it more of a challenge
well you know it's funny because so much
of the show
and the situations that the show
highlights and features
exist because someone wouldn't video
chat
right and that's the one thing that
they've been avoiding that would
essentially
answer all of the questions that exist
you know
and the mystery so it's interesting
because on one hand
you'd think it would be really hard
because they've done such a good job of
avoiding it
this whole time but on the other hand
there is something i think
easier for people about just sort of
flipping on their zoom camera
than it then it might be for us to
actually show up and have to be on
camera with a whole crew around
so i think it goes both ways because
there's a little less
um ultimatum involved you know the the
sense that like well we're coming and
we're gonna knock on your door
so you kind of don't have a choice
definitely
isn't there as much but at the same time
it's so easy for them to finally say you
know what all right i've been avoiding
this like
click i'll do it so it kind of kind of
feels like it goes both ways
but when you get that zoomed in i know
it's so it's honestly it gives me more
anxiety
yeah when we're in the car like we're
driving up you know i know that
we're going but in this case with the
virtual episodes we give out our zoom id
link to a bunch of different people and
it could be
an informant it could be the catfish
themselves you just never know who's
gonna pop
it right uh you guys have a lot of celeb
fans over the
over the years is there anybody still
that sort of blows you away when you
found out
that they were a fan of the show
mine is an eves fan it's ariana grande
that one i'm like ah i love it i love
her
uh i don't know i mean i i recently
found out
that noah cyrus is like a big fan of the
show and really
yeah i mean and i i didn't realize that
i'd actually been hearing her song and
music and liked her and so it was cool
she had me on our podcast
it's fun because it's the show just sort
of exists
in this orbit around the world and it's
constantly playing for hours and hours
on end of different countries and so you
never know where someone's going to come
across it
and find it whether they're at a hotel
somewhere or
um you know they just stumbled across it
on hulu it's
it's constantly kind of acquiring new uh
viewers when you guys first started this
after you had told
your story and i assumed
one it was a brilliant idea but two that
this show was only going to be around
for about a year
because as soon as you blew the top on
all of this people would just not do
this anymore
you would think so what is the matter
with people
you know i i think that the same
you know you could call it naivete or in
some cases
willful ignorance um and in some cases
even
stupidity that gets people into these
situations
is this is is also the the beautiful
exciting uh fun
thing that makes life so unpredictable
and and makes love so attractive i
you know that if we all made great
decisions all the time
what would we be doing uh the world
would probably be pretty boring
so as long as humans are imperfect and
continue to make decisions
with their heart or with their gut or
with their head and
sometimes incorrectly i think there's
always
going to be a show do you ever forget is
do you ever get a sense that somebody
may not recover or they may be a little
bit more broken
over being catfished than others
sometimes i think you know we definitely
try to encourage people to you know seek
professional help if that's something
that they need
um we always try to leave the situation
you know
on a positive note in a sense um to try
to
just encourage people to know that like
life is going to go on after this
because
you know most of these people are from
smaller towns the show comes out and
then everybody in their town knows that
they were on the show and it can either
be
like the best thing ever and like they
get free starbucks or it can be
you know like something different and so
i think we always try to encourage
people to seek whatever
it is that they need my go-to was like
just take care of yourself
like self-care is the number one thing
and i think if a lot of people were
doing some of that beforehand
maybe they wouldn't be in the situation
that they're in now
and uh quickly before we go everybody's
working from home now you guys have had
to do this show which means opening up
your lives and your homes and we see
where you live and we're looking at
families and everything else how has
that been
for for you to kind of like open up a
little bit more than
than you would have normally on this
show i mean i
i kind of like it because it was an
excuse to
finally kind of get our guest our little
guest house
you know fixed up and cleaned and
go through all those closets and kind of
move you know
move some stuff around um but it's also
fun because
now i'm i'm with my wife and kids at my
dad's house in long island
and i wasn't obviously planning on
filming here but here we are and so now
i've actually kicked my dad out of his
bedroom because it's
the only room in the house that's big
enough that i can also close the door
so i can have some kind of privacy uh
but it's funny again it's
it's these weird unexpected twists and
turns in life uh in situations that you
find yourself in that you didn't think
you'd ever be in that
that gave you things to talk about and
make life fun and interesting
and same for you cammy i agree i mean
i'm
actually i just moved into a new
apartment so you know that's not
necessarily
ideal for filming purposes i still have
boxes that are going to be in the
background
some scenes for our next episode but
that's real life and like this is what
people are doing this is what we're
actually doing like we're
you know we're moving around we're doing
things so you know it's
it is what it is everybody's got to see
it it's you know i have to just make
sure everything is clean
all the time which isn't just you know
i like it because i get to sort of i get
to see what cami's up to
and tease her about stuff and it's fun
yeah where's that awesome like cammy do
the exercise bike make the move
yes it's there it's in there it's in
there it has not reviewed here yet
i've been picking up boxes i've been
very you know
yes you guys are the best thank you so
much uh the show is fantastic
i'm sorry about my my two cats in the
background over there
love it that's family right there there
we go
uh anyway wonderful uh to speak to you
guys and uh all the best okay thank you
so much you too take it easy appreciate
it
you